hello everyone
welcome to interpreting ml models with
explainable ai
my name is sarah robinson i'm a
developer advocate on google cloud
this is an overview of what i'm going to
be covering in this session
i'm going to start by defining some key
terms related to
model explainability then we'll see some
examples of
what explainability looks like for
different data types then we'll dive
into the explainable ai
offerings that we have on google cloud
today
and finally we'll see them in action
with some live demos
so let's get started i'm going to start
by defining explainability
now in order to understand
explainability i want to set the stage
and
tell you how it fits into the larger
concept of
responsible ai responsible ai
is essentially the practice of ensuring
that ai benefits society
and doesn't reinforce unfair bias so you
can think of explainable ai as an
umbrella concept
and explainability is a subfield within
responsible ai
in addition to other topics like
fairness
privacy and security so this is a
summary of how
explainability fits into the larger
responsible ai picture
i want to talk about fairness and
explainability since there are two terms
and concepts that
work together and can sometimes be
confused so when i talk about fairness
i'm talking about ensuring that
machine learning models don't reinforce
biases and subsequently that they treat
all different slices of users of a
machine learning model fairly and
equitably
explainability is one way to ensure
fairness
explainability refers specifically to
understanding
how and why a machine learning model
makes predictions
but explainability can also be used
outside the context of fairness to do
something like
maybe explaining why a fraud detection
model flagged a particular transaction
as fraudulent
explainability is a broad concept and
can invoke
a variety of related concepts depending
on who's looking at it so maybe for an
executive that's overseeing ai
investments they might think of
explainability as
transparency accountability or
governance
in this presentation we're going to
focus specifically on model
explainability
which is understanding how machine
learning models make predictions
and communicating the insights from that
to external stakeholders
and folks within an organization that
are building these models
so now let's see some examples of what
model explainability looks like
this depends largely on the type of data
that you're working with the data that
you use to train your model
so explainability is going to look a bit
different for image
text and tabular models so let's take a
look
for image models explainability can
highlight the specific pixels or regions
in an image
that caused a model to predict a certain
label for an image
so in this example the image on the left
of the dog
is the original image and the other two
images show
different methods of getting
attributions
for the pixels in an image that signaled
the model's prediction
for text models explainability can tell
us the words
in a block of text that contributed to a
model's prediction
so in this example the sentence how
could you not love cake
which our model gave a sentiment score
of 0.9
we can also see the words that
contributed most to that model's
prediction of a high sentiment
and this is an example of how
explainability and fairness can go hand
in hand
so in a text specifically a sentiment
analysis model
you'd want to make sure that your model
wasn't using identity terms
to determine the model's sentiment in
this example it looks like our model is
performing correctly because it's
picking up on
emotion words and words like not to make
its sentiment
prediction and then finally for tabular
models
explainability gives attribution values
for each of the features in your model
to show how they influence the
prediction
this particular example shows a model
that predicts the duration of a bike
trip
and we can see here that the distance of
a trip
of this specific trip caused the models
predicted trip duration to decrease
whereas the max temperature on that day
caused the model's predicted duration to
increase
we talk about model explanations there
are a few different groups of people
that need explanations the first group
is
data scientists people who are building
models maybe people who are managing the
operations
and productionizing those models and for
that group of people
they want to use explanations to
understand maybe strange behavior in
their model and help debug it
see why the model is not performing as
they expect and try to improve the model
end users of ml systems could refer to a
few different types of
groups of people first it could refer to
someone that's benefiting from a
prediction of an ml model
maybe you're using an application that
gives you a product recommendation
it could also refer to a practitioner
maybe a doctor or medical practitioner
who is using a machine learning model to
determine
whether an x-ray contains a particular
disease
in this case they're using explanations
to verify that they can trust the
model's output
finally we have public stakeholders
anyone involved in regulatory or
compliance for machine learning models
and this could be somebody both within
or outside your organization
they're using explanations to determine
uh whether a model complies with certain
regulations
and if the model is safe and fit for
purpose
and each of these types of users will
take different action
as a result of explanations so just to
go over this
a little bit so data scientists model
builders people who are actually
building these models
might use explanations to go back and
see where they could improve training
data
maybe refine features or change the
model architecture
end users are using explainability to
have more trust in ml systems and be
confident that the model is leading them
in the right direction
finally public stakeholders might take
action from explanations by
using higher level summaries of models
to develop guidance for different
industries
on responsible ai
now let's look at how we can use
explainable ai on google
cloud today i'm going to focus primarily
on what's called feature attributions
but first i want to talk about two
categories of explainable
machine learning the first is referred
to as post-hoc explanation methods
this involves looking at relationships
between feature values
and a model's given prediction
independent of model internals
things like learned weights the other
type of explainability is called
methods that are interpretable by design
and this refers to
simpler models like linear regression
models or decision trees
and looking specifically at the
architecture of those models to
understand explainability tabnet
presents some new research
in interpretable machine learning models
for tabular data and we recently
released a solution for it on google
cloud
today i'm going to be focusing
specifically on post hoc explanation
methods and within that category we'll
be looking at
feature attributions now let's look at
the products on google
cloud where you can use explainable ai
this pyramid provides an overview of the
different machine learning offerings
that we have on google cloud
organized by levels of abstraction so
the products that are on the bottom half
of the pyramid are targeted more towards
data scientists and machine learning
engineers folks that have more of a
background in machine learning
as we move towards the top these
products are targeted towards data
analysts
application developers folks that want a
way to integrate machine learning into
their application
but may not have as much ml experience
right now you can use explainable ai on
tensorflow models that you deploy to ai
platform prediction
along with models that you tabular data
models that you deploy
to automl tables and with automl tables
you get access to explainable ai
by default later on in the presentation
i'm going to show live demos of both of
these tools and how to use explainable
ai with them
the first demo is going to show how to
use automl tables and
in this demo i'm going to show a fraud
detection model that was trained on a
public data set that's available in
bigquery
and we'll show how we can use
explainable ai to get both global
and instance level explanations for the
second demo
i built an image classification model
trained on medical images
using tensorflow and deployed that to ai
platform with explanations
for the first model i train this model
using a publicly available data set from
bigquery
and explainable ai provides both global
and instance level feature attributions
in automl tables so this means i can see
overall
which features my model relied on most
to make predictions and i can also
zoom in and see at an instance level for
an individual prediction
which features were most important for
that one prediction
for the second demo i trained a
tensorflow model on
this chest x-ray data set available in
kaggle
and i'm going to show how we're going to
use explainable ai's new local
experience
sdk to get explanations without
deploying our model
this sdk is available in cloud ai
platform notebooks
and i can use it to get explanations on
a model that's available within my
notebooks instance
as i'm developing and prototyping my
model without needing
to deploy it to ai platform
when you're deploying a model to ai
platform with explanations
you can choose the explanation method
that you're going to use
so i want to introduce the three
explanation methods that we have
available
all these explanation methods are based
on publicly available research
that you can check out by going to the
links on this slide the first method is
called integrated gradients
this works with all types of models
built with tensorflow tabular
image and text models sample chaplet
works for tabular models built with
tensorflow
and the x-ray method is built on top of
integrated gradients
and does some smoothing to show instead
of pixel-based image attributions
it shows region based attributions
and this is one way that you could
deploy explainable models to ai platform
here we're showing how to do this using
the gcloud google cloud cli to do it
so this looks very similar to how you
would deploy a model version without
explainability on ai platform
the only things you need to add are the
explanation method you'd like to use
and the number of steps you'd like this
method to use and i'll get into that a
little bit more in the demo
so now let's go to the demo i'm going to
train my fraud detection model using
this public bigquery data set of credit
card transactions here's a description
of the data
and the schema most of the columns in
this data set have been obscured
and here's a preview of what the data
looks like i'm going to run a quick
query to show as
in the case of many fraud detection data
sets the data is heavily imbalanced
meaning that only a very small
percentage of our examples
are fraudulent transactions so to
account for this i have
done some down sampling which means that
i've taken just a small sample
of the data from our majority class and
to keep things interesting i've also
taken the liberty of
renaming the column names that were
obscured
so let's look at automl tables so to
import my data i can import it directly
from bigquery so i don't need to move my
data anywhere
i've already done this so let's take a
look at what the data looks like
i can see a preview of my columns and
the different types here as you can see
i have renamed many of the columns and
i've selected my target column
now to train my model in automl tables
all i need to do is press this train
model button
and to account for that class and
balance that i mentioned in addition to
the down sampling i did
i can also use this optimization
objective provided by automl tables so
in this case i chose
to maximize my model's performance on
the less common class in this case
our fraudulent transactions
i've already trained this model so let's
take a look
here we can see many of the different
evaluation metrics for our model
the confusion matrix tells us the
percentage of examples in our test set
that our model classified correctly for
each class
and here we care most about our
fraudulent examples and we can see that
our model did a pretty good job
with no false positives and it was able
to classify
88 of our test examples correctly
now let's get into explainable ai so we
get this out of the box once we trade an
automl tables model we don't have to
enable anything
what this provides is global model level
feature importance
so across our test set this shows us
which features
our model used most in influencing its
prediction
and looks like the the most important
feature here was whether or not there
was a smiley face on the credit card
signature
followed by the credit card color again
i just made up these feature names
and so once we have trained and
evaluated our model the next thing we
want to do is use it to get predictions
and there's a couple of ways to do this
in automl tables we can do it right in
the ui which i'll show first
automall tables has just populated each
feature with a random value
and what i want to do here is check this
generate feature importance box
here we can see the model is 99
confident that this is not a fraudulent
transaction
and here we can sort our feature
attribution values
by the ones with the highest absolute
value so here we can see that
smiley face signature caused the model's
prediction confidence to go down
whereas the time to expiration caused
the prediction
confidence to go up and we can scroll
through and
look at the other feature attribution
values here as well
so that's how we can try out automl
tables and see feature importance at an
instance level in the ui
but chances are we also want to use the
automl tables prediction api
to generate predictions and get feature
importance so i'm going to show you how
to do this in a python notebook
using the automl tables api so first
we'll create an auto multables client
and we'll set up some variables for our
project and the specific model version
i have provided my inputs in this format
uh this is an example of a fraudulent
transaction so hopefully our model will
predict
fraud for this one and notice here that
i am setting feature importance to true
to get those feature attribution values
back in my response
here i'm visualizing the feature
attribution values we can see that our
model predicted this correctly
97 confidence that this was a fraudulent
transaction and
here i've graphed the feature
attribution values
just for the top five features
and we can see which features influenced
our model's prediction of
fraud here
now that we've seen an example of a
tabular model using automl tables
i'm going to show a few examples of how
to get explanations on an
image model using explainable ai i'm
going to show you how to do it in cloud
ai platform notebooks
using the explainable ai sdk which comes
pre-installed in notebooks instances
so i'll open up my notebook instance
here
and in this notebook i'm going to show
you two examples of
image classification models that i've
built with tensorflow
what i'm going to highlight is how you
can do this all locally from within your
notebooks instance
so i'm going to get explanations on my
models without having to
deploy them to the cloud both of the
models that i'll be using for this demo
i've already saved in the tensorflow
saved model format in these directories
here the first model
that i'm going to show you is a model
that's been trained on the imagenet data
set
which can classify images into a
thousand different labels
ranging from different types of animals
food plants etc
so i've already saved the model assets
in the tensorflow saved model format
into this directory
and note that i'm importing the
explainable ai sdk here
when i point the sdk at this directory
it's going to generate some metadata
that it will need
to provide explanations we can see it
save this in a json file here
and now we're ready to send a test image
to the model
i'm going to send it this image of a
jellyfish i'm going to see both
what label the model returns for this
image along with the feature
attributions
to explain that prediction
and again to do this i am using this
load model from local path method
and i didn't need to deploy my model to
the cloud to take advantage of this
what we see here is the label index for
the label that my model was most
confident in
and below you can see that the index of
108 corresponds to the label of
jellyfish which is a good sign because
this
is indeed a jellyfish and looks like our
model was 96
competent in that prediction
and just so you understand what these
color-coded explanations mean
the yellow brighter regions in the image
are the regions that contributed most to
my model's prediction
the darker purple colored regions are
the regions that were least
important in predicting this label and
so what we're trying to see here is that
our model is picking up on the right
shapes that are associated with this
particular label
and in this case we can verify that our
model is performing correctly it's
looking at shapes in this image that are
specific to
that of a jellyfish which we can see
here
the next model we'll look at is a model
that was trained on a
chest x-ray data set in kaggle to
predict
the presence of one condition that can
be found
in these images so the first thing we're
going to do is save our model
metadata and here we're explicitly
setting the baseline for this model
to be a solid black image and that's
what all of our explanations will be
relative to
we can preview the metadata here so
we're going to
test out our model using this image
and our model output is a sigmoid output
which means that it's going to output a
value between zero and one
with one indicating that the model
thinks a specific condition is present
zero indicating that it does not
so we'll first get an explanation and
notice here that we've set our model's
step count
to 10 this is the number of integral
steps that the explanation method is
going to use in computing the pixel
attribution values
and we can see here that the
approximation error exceeds five percent
now what this means is that we may not
be able to trust the explanations in
this particular example
one way that we can decrease this error
is to
increase the number of integral steps
we're using so let's try
increasing the step count to 50 and
generate a new explanation
now we can see that the approximation
error did decrease significantly but
looking closer at this image
the regions that our model seems to be
focusing on
are not the correct regions associated
with this particular condition
for this particular image our model
should have predicted closer to
one this is likely pointing to a problem
with our model
or a need to improve the data that was
used to train our model since
explanations are only
a direct reflection of your model
they're only going to be as good as your
model itself
so it looks like here we need to go back
and improve our training data perhaps
provide
a more varied representation of x-rays
that have this
specific condition present and healthy
x-rays
once we have a model that we're happy
with and the explanations confirm
that our model is performing correctly
we have everything right here ready to
go to deploy our model to ai platform
so all we would need to do is copy this
directory with this metadata file to
google cloud storage
and we could do that here and then we
would run this gcloud command
to deploy our model and now let's go
back to the slides
and finally here are some resources if
you want to get started with any of the
products that i covered in this
presentation
i definitely recommend checking out our
sample code we have some example
notebooks
that show you how to deploy explainable
models on ai platform
thank you for watching if you want to
get in touch you can find me on twitter
at
srob tweets and i hope you enjoy the
rest of next on air